gender identity gender fluidity gender
is on everyone's lips right now we've
seen some profound changes like the
legalization of gay marriage in many
countries and a more open approach to
sexuality and we're grappling as a
society with the idea that gender is not
purely biological
but is this really so new we could learn
a lot from the poet Sappho who lived in
the sixth century BC on the Greek island
of Lesbos it's because of her that we
used the word lesbian which originally
just meant someone from lesbos sweet
mother I cannot weave slender Aphrodite
has overcome me with longing for a girl
her poetry made her famous in antiquity
but the ways in which she and her work
have been treated show only too well
what it is to be judged and labeled if
suffer were alive now would she identify
as a lesbian woman would she celebrate
the freedom of identity choice what
would she think of our debates about
gender answering these questions is a
challenge because much of surfers work
is lost but the little we have is
remarkable in a day it made her one of
the few women to be pictured on pottery
the ancient Greek equivalent of
appearing on primetime TV we can't know
for sure whether she had sexual
relationships with women and if so
whether she was open about them but in
ancient Greece it would have been no
cause for scandal although men and women
were expected to marry homosexual
feelings and relationships were seen as
normal so all we have to go on is the
poems themselves sex and sexuality is
everywhere here may I write words more
naked than flesh stronger than bone more
resilient than sinew more sensitive than
nerve once again love drives me on that
loosener of limbs bittersweet creature
against which nothing can be done
suffers poems play with our expectations
of gender and set up teasing questions
about sexuality who is speaking
male or female who is the beloved may
or female one of her best-known poems is
spoken by someone looking at a beautiful
girl and envying the man talking to her
that man seems to me to be equal to the
gods he who sits opposite you and hears
you nearby speaking sweetly and laughing
delightfully which indeed makes my heart
beat faster translators from the 15th
century on have assumed that the speaker
the person who desires the beautiful
girl is another man but in the original
there's a big hint that this isn't so
there's a line clora terra de Porres
Emme
I am greener than grass the word plura
Terra in the Greek is the form you would
use if it were a woman speaking Sappho
wanted her poetry to make people think
about experiences that are transgender
or that transcend gender she wanted them
to imagine the feelings of agenda to
which you do not or may not belong
suffers perms on her most important
subjects sex and love are about everyone
they are gender fluid and they are
gender blind Sappho does not care who we
love it is still love so she might tell
us don't worry about labels just get on
and be who you are after all she did
write some say an army of horsemen
others say foot soldiers still others
say a fleet of ships is the finest thing
on the
I say it is whatever one tops